what I don't like is when guys who are
very disciplined in all areas of their
life come out and say preach discipline
rightfully so but then we'll say well
let's not apply it to our sex lives
because that's just not for me right and
it's like well you know what it may not
be for you but when it when you make it
sound like it's outside of your control
that's where you lose me you may choose
you may say well I want to have you know
one wife and 50 girlfriends but if I
really wanted to change that I would and
I but what it sounds like is all of a
sudden some of these guys become
helpless and they're like puppets to
their eggplant for better lack of a
better word they're like you know I can
be disciplined in every area of life but
what the eggplant tells me to do I gotta
do and that's not that to me demeans
your value